[Music]
well it's a special st patrick's day
edition of the golden knights tonight
vegas is looking for their fourth win
in a row john treach is covering that
game he joins us live outside the
t-mobile arena
hey john hey there christian yeah all
due respect to our chris
our irish brothers and sisters but i
tell you what it should be the luck of
the golden knights as
as well in three years three playoff
appearances so it's fair to say they're
going for more
in year four that's right big picture
the knights aim for four straight post
seasons in the present they look to win
four games in a row
san jose has been rather accommodating
to that feat this year
and they hope to break the seal on the
teal once again tonight
despite their success the wild and
avalanche are still breathing down
vegas neck in the west standings so
while the shark show coming to town is
one of the worst in the league vgk can't
afford to relax
credit our group with the streaks
because you're never going to have your
a game over
over three six seven eight games
you're going to have some games there
through those stretches where
you know either your energy's not there
or uh
you know you're uh you're mentally
fatigued and
and especially as you get into the the
meat of the season which we're in right
now
the schedule starts to really catch up
on you so you've got to win different
ways
yeah you're appeared the board pretty
optimistic there and robin winter is
back the goaltender
nursing a concussion he's back with the
team so that's good news and for st
patrick's day as i can refix my mask
here how about a uh
a golden knights limerick yeah beating
the sharks is fun
but the work is far from done fleury
will save with grace reeves will punch
your face
and vegas will hoist the cup in 2021.
all right thank you reporting live john
treach 8 sports now